ось тут у нас канцелярії святого
Миколая Святого Миколая безкоштовно прах
та стріли у спортивному клубі у житомирі
за містрис для ніг декорації фіча оленів
тут портрети тих хто пішов на фронт that
їх хто до нього не обернувся самий з них
і дітьми це дружинам і купе кається
аллах жваво, до німецької громади
євромайдан первинного рейну-вестфалії
діти писали десь писали списки не
фахівці святого Миколая
але а ми через бочки в цілості при х
плював ще парі дата тему маккалоу і вигляд
по видно за своїм списком закупівля вали
подарунки вже купували подарунки у сили
стику ж аллах підкорялася астраханія
промив у краї не пройти ще дітям за
губи хвої не в боготу чого шлюбу я їх не
бажання з бібер кроку
ту ж скромну ми не хочемо ми не хочемо
ажурних подарунки я по метаються лист
мама теж хоче сковорідку tefal me по
видно святим ecolife та кланів так я про
ханія виконав таке прохання дур з 2
посмішку вітру базі дві дати десятки рудин
його списку 69 дітей і чекають на
адже подарунки святого Миколая
випущу
пульпу укол посмішку вага 45 руки
cool та гойдалася away на на фронті його не
взяв і там вчив віки став волонтером так
допомагаючи синім за гиблих особливі вас 95
аеромобільної бригади ще ж тамара
аджику лодзь і сам не служив 25
роккі ви на початку бойових дій мої ж
кожному можна було назвати і волонтерам
загадаю олег жваво
тепер же люди ви сну не те в тому і
ниві двіною
дощу руди щодо витрачала людину
тютюну всю провину вже nicoline і пофарбувати
Чи ти сам цю каламуть і людина складають
рук 1 українка та двоє німців усміхнулася
вона почала 2014 руку спину ту
євромайдан п'ятничний рейн-вестфалія
так я просто подумав я і огром 1-а з світ
ще є інший для України спочатку
активісти упікання волосся майдані в team
це летячи маяк їх тріумфував і поза матчем і не
нині допомагають з більш містом нам за
загиблих dokumu подарунком і does what a
деку мишею місячну фінансову пит ринку
you за голом допомогу вдалося і вібрато
для близького 300 руди на кілок і така
бачиш не можеш просто виду are not і
себе хочеться петром і активісти пар
ікона не впевнені на сході України може
бути і 1 і ви рішенням путін і ще путін
скажеш про його біжениці кувати україна
завтра ж закінчиться вина шляхом громада
готова дату вище на зливки та війни дала
туди видати ціни один рік пройдуся їм
психологічні травми дітей малих купа
в проти ти на цмв сьогодні так тут
вона жива дівчинка соня в але ту ж хочеш
буде і гарною
там його називала святому миколі накладі
не hti
нігті нігті
написала святому Миколаю нігті нігті
олег дубу дик ведіть а чого бажання
ставити саду ж серйозному гарна
сподобалися про джейсон вигляд та бачка
вадима антонова зал і шила сили 6 приводи
фотографії ми дали щось морська свинка я
куріння подарував
боєць нацгвардії за провину 10 серпня 2014
року це був бій із собою убий
розвідка боєм помилково cool і відвезла
вела війська на залізніть вишів за
лизніть
і снайпер проти снайпера працював раниш
а батька правда собою роль святого
Микола виродки не
тепер свята дітям на пірс і рутом
допомагає ство ритий аллах the movie hd
s2 знаряддя що там і сільські та дороги та
рахунок шкірно дітей на ранок молоці пробач
попросила святого Миколая